Josie Loeb uses a responsive
neurostimulator implanted in her brain
to help prevent seizures essentially
making her a real bionic woman and a 200
million dollar plant in Maryland is
being built to create energy out of
chicken poop Vsauce Kevin here this is
mind blow a new study shows that babies
learn faster from surprises when
presented with an object that defied
their expectations babies not only paid
more attention to it but also created
and tested hypotheses around their
confusion for example when a ball
appeared to roll through a wall they
tested its solidity by slamming it
against the table showing babies use
what they know about the world to
motivate learning and the researchers
are trying to understand how much
knowledge humans are born with and how
much is from a result of our
observations of the world a new 3d
printer can form soft objects using
fabric utilizing sheets of off-the-shelf
fabric layers are bonded with a heat
sensitive adhesive and the contour is
shaped with a laser cutter it can even
include conductive fabric to sense touch
as well as a fabric coil for wireless
power reception for a soft cell phone
case nineteen hundred and sixty two feet
below the gulf of mexico
researchers from evey Nautilus had a
rare encounter with a sperm whale the
remotely operated vehicle piqued the
interest of the whale and hearing the
researchers reactions is just great
why I think we beat the other watch NASA
recently unveiled their modular robotic
vehicle the LRV is a fully electric car
with autonomous and remote control
featuring four independent wheel modules
capable of steering 180 degrees it has a
top speed of 40 miles per hour and they
claim the sideways driving is like
driving an ice but in complete control
aside from Moon and Mars driving
applications could manifest in
retirement communities or taxi services
Parkinson's diagnosis may be possible by
typing on a keyboard current diagnosis
happens about five to ten years after
the onset of the disease but by
analyzing the subtleties and people's
keystrokes we can learn a great deal
about psychomotor performance
researchers noticed a huge difference
between people typing wall wide awake
and then typing after being woken up in
the middle of the night and they hope to
develop a way to use this kind of data
for early detection of Parkinson's
meanwhile General Atomics is building
the world's largest superconducting
electromagnet the 1000 ton eater central
solenoid will be used to drive a hot
plasma for fusion energy it'll be among
the most powerful magnets ever built
with six modules housing the energy of a
thousand cars going a hundred miles per
hour the international nuclear fusion
research mega project is a collaboration
between 35 nations to demonstrate the
viability of fusion energy finally
researchers at Pacific Northwest
National Laboratory view of battery
under a special microscope to see why a
battery loses strength over time each
discharge of the battery leaves behind
lithium metal in this trapped state the
dead lithium can't contribute to a
future charge you can also see the
electrode cracking from stress I'm gonna
leave you with a pack planter robot
transplanting rows of pansies and as
always thanks for watching
you
hey so vsauce has been nominated for a
Webby for science and education so go
vote you only have a few days so just do
it now
probably yeah oh now vote now vote vote
now now now